tonight more las vegas properties now
permitted to operate at full
capacity with the plexi glass barriers
removed at table games and machines
eight news now reporter sally hademia
was live on the las vegas strip with
reaction and
also what this means for our state sally
denise people i spoke to say they are
overly excited
this means very good news they no longer
have to be overly concerned about social
distancing on casino floors this will
definitely help bring some normalcy back
mgm resorts international announced
today that its las vegas properties got
approval by the nevada gaming control
board to be at 100 percent capacity
that's valajo aria mgm grand mandalay
bay park mgm the mirage new york new
york luxury
and excalibur but it doesn't stop there
as we know last monday wynn
and encore became the first casinos to
operate at full capacity
cosmopolitan followed the next day the
strat the silverton
caesars entertainment as well as station
casinos all have the approval
masks are still required and while the
while these properties return to 100
capacity travel influencers will
definitely be posting about us
these influencers are now a major part
of selling las vegas anna linares is a
travel influencer who lives in miami
every place she visits she documents the
most fascinating places there are to
visit
and enjoys including on the strip and
beyond
it was really important for me with my
platform to share
with the community how vegas is taking
over what the new restrictions are
and how you can travel responsibly
tonight at six in my special report i
will explain how the lbcba and
influencers like anna are selling las
vegas through the use of social media
platforms such as
instagram i'll also show you how she
promotes las vegas through ig reels and
how important 10 seconds
is to influence you and hey let me tell
you something that is how long it took
me to say all this reporting live
here in the strip sally jaramillo 8 news
now